hello everyone and welcome back to the
warm-up for the 2020 candidates
tournament for this video I prepared the
first-ever decisive game between
Alexander Grisha and Fabiano Caruana now
like I said it was played in 2010 in the
world blitz championship and Fabi is
around 18 here and Grisha Keyes is 27
and what do you think is there well now
in 2020 as they will meet in the
candidates tournament what is their head
head score you know they're a lifetime
record in classical games what do you
think who has the upper hand in in that
matchup now I've prepared it here just
so you check it out we've seen that Fabi
is equal with the ding but ding is
something better if we include rapid
games but here with Grisha
his score is actually three wins Fabi
three wins agree shop and 11 draw so in
classical games he's tied but including
rapid exhibition games Alexander you've
tied Fabiana Khurana 21 to 21 with 29
draw so if you include the faster time
formats it's 21 wins Fabi 21 wins Grisha
and 29 draws so completely equal include
if you include all time formats so it
just in case you were interested I don't
know maybe you thought that maybe maybe
Fabi had had had a better score against
Grisha but he doesn't so that being said
let's check out this a very nice game so
Grisha quit the white pieces opens with
c4 he goes for the English opening we
have Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now
II five the two knights variation of the
English Knight of three and the night to
seasick we have the four Knights of the
English with g3a Grisha progressive in
Cairo is LightSquared Bishop and mount
Knight
to d4 immediately is throwing some
trouble here asking do you want to maybe
capture on e5 but you all know there is
no such thing as a free pawn sometimes
there is but most more often than not
there isn't for example Queen e7 attacks
the night and now you have to be very
careful for example if you go back then
just nightcap force on f3 is meeting one
and a lot of things can go wrong here so
instead I just got continue developing
Bishop g2 now and now Knight captures on
f3
with Bishop captures an f3 and Bishop to
b4 fabi's pet line at least in those
days he defeated some very strong
players with this line with castles
bigger issue castles by Fabi and d3
continuing development we have c6
preparing to strike in the center with
the d5 and there should be back to g2
now we have h6 taking away the g5 square
from Grisha bishop and the disrupted d2
we've looked at eh old considered
standard theory of this line at the time
look the c1 and now a6 preparing to
strike with b5 so here our black has the
option of either busting open which
would be 5 or with d5 with King to h1
saying that at some point he's
definitely interested in playing f4 and
now d6 first and here there is one game
also from 2010 between an Akita we to go
and maxime beaugeois grafted ended in a
draw or a3 was played but here Grisha
attempts f4 and it is as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see how far be deals with it Fabi goes
he captures an f4 we have rook captures
on f4 and saying that ok if you capture
here I want to capture back with the
bishop and now Bishop to g4 putting a
lot of pressure on his eat you pawn
saying it at any point I can just
capture the defender of the pawn here
and then pick up the pawn so Queen to b3
saying okay you go ahead and do this it
is possible for example if Bishop
captures in c3
you're gonna go Bishop captures and c3
and then now well you can capture here
there's a lot of pressure on the f6 bond
and also you can also pick up the b7
pawn so not not as great for black so
after this Queen to b3 move Bishop back
to c5 by Fabi and now II for getting rid
of the weakness and grabbing more space
in the center
finally b5 by Fabi and now rook seat f1
nicely doubling up on the F file and
Bishop to d4 now still Reema nuvaring
preparing to bring this bishop over to
b5 to force to look back and also it's a
very nice central square for the bishop
we have Queen back to c2 and now comes B
captures on c4 we have D captures on c4
and and Bishop to e5 as planned
so like I said it's a blitz game so not
a lot of time to consider your options
look back to f2 it is the best reply
from white and Bishop back to e6 now
trying to go after this point here so
Knight the e2 the Queen defends the c4
pawn also you want to bring this Knight
over to f4 where you can maybe force a
trade of the bishops as both black and
white still do have the bishop pair but
now as Grisha colluded and the Fabi it
wants to get rid of his weak bonds at
some point he executed d5 we have it
captures a sea captain d5 and now Knight
to f4 problem with capturing CD 5 is
well black is gonna get a lot of contra
play after this for example Bishop
captures here and it's not clear how to
go about this for example if something
like captures captures with check you're
gonna run into a lot of trouble for
example King to g1 now Knight to e4 and
there's an attack on the rook and also a
double attack on the bishop here and
you're gonna you're definitely losing
something here for example if Knight c3
you attack the Queen you just pick up
the knight captures captures with
whatever and then you pick up one of the
rooks and you're just up the exchange
and in in a winning position
so after this C characters in d5 no
recapture from Grisha but rather Knight
to f4 and he keeps tension here of
course if Fabi captures then you can
just pick up the roof and he says okay
I'm definitely interested in picking up
your light square bishop so far B says
okay I'm gonna give up the dark square
bishop we have Bishop captures rook
captures and only now Fabi plays D
captures and c4 winds upon and offers
the exchange so can you grab the rook
you could but for example if Bishop
captures Queen captures this comes with
check King g1 now Queen a7 check checks
on a dark square and the King has no
well here the King has light scores but
you don't want to allow this bishop to
d5 checks so what you could do here is
something like rook f2 but then Knight
g4 and you will either win back material
or pose a lot of problems for white for
a forget for the rest of the game but
either way you will be better for
example if Bishop c3 just a normal move
you just go look to d8 and the
who you already have ideas like captures
maybe maybe we want to capture back rook
and come to the back rank and it's gonna
be it's gonna be a tough tough game for
white so here in this kind of position
you want to play a slow move but it's
hard to hard to play a slow-mo of course
in a blitz games you want to play
something like Bishop the c3 put even
more pressure on f6 and so on slowly a
pile up but a Grisha said okay let's
just let's just go for it
rook captures on f6 and okay Fabi
recharacterize G captures an f6 and now
Bishop to c3 so first he decided to give
up the exchange and now he's ready to
capture on f6 either with the bishop or
with the rook depending on what Fabi
plays Fabi says okay now this is AB you
your light square Bishop is it's quite
excellent let's trade it Bishop the d5
and now there are a lot of options here
but mostly agree shook realized that he
definitely has a lot of back rank issues
so he played h4 here giving his King
some breeding squares for example if you
play something like rook captures and f6
with ideas of maybe I don't know
capturing here followed by Queen h7 it
looks promising but there's one little
problem and I'm sure you know what it is
but if you don't immediately see feel
free to pause the video and what is the
immediate refutation by black of this
rook captures an f6 move while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations I'm sporting a free rook
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show of course its Queen
captures and f6 point is that if Bishop
captures now and well if you don't
you're just I mean down too much
material rook e1 is made you can unblock
because well there's nothing to block
with the bishop is pinned and it's just
made and it's no different if after
Bishop d5 you play Bishop captures you
just attack the Queen and you keep the
rook here because still Queen captures
and after real captures rook e1 with
check you can block with the rule but
still rook captures is made to do to the
the exact same thing so Greek realizes
that there definitely are back rank
issues and he gives himself some reading
space with h4
now pharmacist Bishop captures and now
of course if King captures then Queen to
d3 will be a lot of problems for
judicial key he's not in a position to
trade queens
so he goes Queen captures but still
Queen to b3 by Fabi putting a lot of
pressure here preparing to do a nice
roof lifts woodwork to e2 although he
can't do it right away because there's
this awkward Queen captures in a a Czech
move so first King to g1 although
capturing on f6 is possible now and it
is probably the best move from white as
well like I said you cannot go for a
roof level because the rook Hanks and if
you try something like Queen to d1 check
the rook can simply brought a block rook
to f1 but instead aggressive tried King
to g1 he defends the rook now with the
king and now if the rook moves of course
well not there but now if you attack at
it then the Queen can grab the free
broken AAA so here fabbi just goes rook
8 d8 now there's no more threat of
capturing the rook and there he just
made it possible to go for a nice rook
look for example we looked at e2 so now
Grisha goes for rook captures on f6 but
now like I said look the e2 the queen is
under attack and here Queen to h3 and
now if Grisha can gain can somehow get
Quinn to g4 check in it could be it
could be very dangerous for Fabi but the
problem is Fabi now has a forced
checkmate with best defense it's a it's
a forced mate in 7 but I'm sure you you
can sport it you know feel free to pause
the video take as much time as you need
and find this well unstoppable idea from
Fabi well I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
the D unstoppable mate and for those of
you who just wanna enjoy the show of
course it's Quinta III check but it's
important to find all the moves King to
h1
now of course rook to d1 check you also
saw also that one looked f1 blocking and
now Queen f3 check as the route cannot
capture due to the pin so you have to
block King to g1
you get out of check and now comes look
captures on f1
check and it was in this position that
Alexander Grisha resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the Queen has the capture there's there
are no moves so after Queen captures you
get Queen captures here with check and
now it doesn't matter either Queen
blocks and then you capture the Queen
would mate or kink the h1 and then just
what rook or Queen to h2 will be made
so unfortunately game for Greece shock
but you know it's a blitz game and there
were I'm sure there was a lot of tension
during this this game as you know
everything was all over the board
but yam that's the first-ever decisive
game between Grisha and Fabiano Caruana
even though it's a blitz game I decided
to show it as it is very exciting and
well I also wanted you to seed the their
head-to-head score before we go into the
candidates so up until today you know
it's 20 23 wins in classical both with
11 draws and just in case you forgot the
final standings of the 2010 world blitz
championship here it is it was won by
none other than 11
Arnon with 24 and a half points followed
by two motors raja baath with 24 out of
38 and in third place Magnus Carlsen and
then followed by all the rest Boris
Gelfand Hikaru Nakamura Sara hurricane
Vladimir Kramnik sharpener manager of
Peter Svidler Pavillion of Alexander
Grichuk Ralph mom and of Yaya Machine
maxime beaugeois graph of session Dmitry
Andre King Boris crotch of boris
pochenko Fabiano Caruana far in the
backward he was very young at the time
and Ruslan ponomaryov with 12 and a half
but just so we know at the 2010 World
Championship was won by 11 Arnon so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you are prepared for the
candidates tournament 2020 sure it's
gonna be really awesome and also it's
probably amongst the very few things
that aren't canceled in the world and
they have a very strict policies about
safety I'm sure they've taken care of
everything I heard they're testing
players at least another least but
they're testing them twice a day so I'm
pretty sure they have everything handled
and that they shouldn't worry about it
but I don't know it still seems to me
like
they will not be able to give a hundred
percent of them to the game due to the
the coronavirus and everything you know
maybe being somewhere in the back of
their head during the game but we'll see
you know some people say it might make
the games even more interesting but you
will see it it starts tomorrow so it's
gonna be very exciting but yeah yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Bradley Campbell
Robert Nara and Taylor Steven portal
ourself that lien and a Jacob Orlovsky
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - my previous videos
serum thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the Morpheus
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world in this case
that candidates tournament 2020 so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day